So a lot of you have been asking
How do I learn how to do visual effects? to learn visual effects you have to sit down and say...
What effect do I want to do? You choose a single effect and you start from there.
Let's say you want to do lightsabers. It's as simple as going to google and typing how do I do lightsabers?
How do  I set up a green screen? How do I do a lightsaber?
How do I do physics in my 3D program? All that stuff is online or in the program manual.
It's just about having the realization that all that knowledge is actually out there. all right guys
Here's a list of websites that'll help you learn how to do visual effects first off you want about after effects check out videocopilot.net
You want learn about 3DS Max? Check out 3Dtotal.com
[they've] got a bunch of good tutorials in there... also read the manual a lot of good stuff in there.
[have] questions [about] like video formats and editing software things like that check out the creative californians
What else you got Sam? Uhm... wushu motion tracking things like that youtube is actually one of the best resources for this?
obviously the Manual is the
ultimate resource for any of these things that a lot of people tend to look past this just because
It's intimidating by the amount of Pages whatever
It's the best way to learn anything yep
You guys have questions about like how to render things correctly how to get good lighting Google Masters apps mentalray tips
Everything you need to know there
Manual. Yeah read the manual guys...
it's the default question- default answer to everything not email us
So a lot of people ask about going to school for visual effects
[and] I think that's not really the right approach to take because visual effects
Is kind of a subset it's like going to school to learn photoshop?
Like you don't go to school learn photoshop you go to school to learn how to be ...
a photographer and Photoshop is one of your tools if you want to do visual effects start doing it now there's a billion tutorials online
They're going to teach you more than any class on after effects out of college
What do you think the best school for visual effects is?
Honestly, I don't know what the best school for visual effects is because I didn't go to the visual effects school
And you don't need to to learn visual effects at all
but that's not to say there's no use in them because honestly uh going through formal training or
Going through a school or university to learn it is
Also, a pretty good route if you just find yourself struggling and not finding the information you want to learn
They can provide them
You know a lot [of] great resources towards that
however
There is one thing you can get out [of] college that it's a really good art program
Learning a lot of actual fundamental art training fine
Art training is going to guide you quite a bit in learning and understanding how light works how the world works?
And then I'll let all feeds in the visual effects
Learning how to do motion tracking you don't need to go to school for that
There's a [youtube] video that you can watch that don't you pay $30,000 a year to learn about your motion tracking but learning
Like learning how to composite something learning how to match perspectives you're going to get all that to start doing drawing training
Figure studies all those kind of things that you can get on college the other thing you get from a college is
Another thousand people that want to make movies also get a community, so there's a certain
Complexity college, but there's certain things that you might be [looking] for in a school that actually aren't really there